this is by roit and this is where after
years of wandering cliched Vagner
finally settled down at age 60 the world
renowned festival theatre stands as a
monument to vogner and by roit alike to
mark Richard Wagner's 200th birthday the
city is offering guided tours of sites
associated with the legendary composer
yoga Sena everyone thinks of the
festival theater on the green hill of
course but there are many other
reminders not just the famous site such
as Villa van freed but other places
where you can follow in vogner's
footsteps Washington Rashad Wagner moved
to buy a void in 1872 at first he and
his family stayed in a little hotel
called fantasy in the suburb of dawned
off the vogner family's room can still
be viewed here with many of the original
furnishings soon the composer had a
house of his own built in by a void the
villa van feed which is currently
undergoing a painstaking restoration it
was a place where vogner could at last
feel truly at home after years of being
on the move ever a spook he moved often
for professional and political reasons
he was politically persecuted and forced
into exile his finances were shaky too
and he had to flee his creditors but
here for the first time he'd found a
home in villa Van freedom by Hoyt and
this is where he spent the last ten
years of his life Fagin as path can also
be traced through the court garden where
he went for a stroll with his wife
almost daily
Rashaad vogner kept up an active social
life in Beloit receiving guests at home
and going out he often went to the oiler
a tried-and-true old restaurant in the
city center he said to have been partial
to the restaurant stuffed pigeon and
Franconian beer yeah he really ate very
well here and he enjoyed life in my
rhoids
he liked the food and drink very very
much and the oiler was part of that
another key site is Stein clipper & Sons
pianos the company has made the grand
pianos for the annual buy avoid
festivals up to the present day
for his opera passive uh valve Mahad
Stein Kleber built a special instrument
that sounded like church bells known as
the passable Bell everyone who loves
vogner knows these sounds the Bell motif
and pasa fall from the first and third
acts
it's an incredibly forceful sound just
imagine you'd need a bell weighing over
200 thousand kilos to produce a sound
like that
by roids main magnesite remains the
festival theatre a theatre built
specially to perform his works was the
fulfillment of one of the composer's
greatest dreams had he had this built
originally it was a half-timbered wooden
structure now the wooden beams have been
replaced with concrete and reinforced
with steel but renovation is always
needed and that's just what vogner
intended
he always said children create new
things and here were taking another step
to a renovated theater Wagner died on a
trip to Italy in 1883 he is buried in
the garden of Villa VanFleet in Beloit